I'm imagining you out in public, and you've
got your magic wand dangling from your belt,
and some kid's like, "Are you a wizard?"
You're like, "Kind of" And she's like, "What
can you do?"
And you're like, "I can make myself less sad."
Nina, what Harry Potter spell would be the
most useful in your everyday life?
Thanks for asking, Brian.
So I thought a lot about this one because
there's a lot.
There's cleaning spells, there's healing spells,
but I went with the spell that I think is
best for the lazy, which wizard or muggle
with the wand, which is Accio, which is the
summoning charm.
I would never, ever, ever get off my couch
ever again.
I wouldn't do anything.
I wouldn't move.
I would just constantly be zooming stuff over
to myself, like snacks and glasses of water
and my laptop.
Oh my God.
But wouldn't you have to have the glass already
filled with water for that to work?
No, there's another spell to it fill it with
water.
Yeah, but I'm saying you have to pick one
spell.
Oh, I have to pick one.
You're just picking one, kid.
Oh, I didn't that it was one that we could
only use.
I thought it was the most useful.
You get one.
I'm still picking it.
I'll think, "I'll spill some water.
I'll figure it out."
So you're going with Brian's whole a web shoes
argument from the other day.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, from our other video.
Yeah, I'm just like, "I don't want to get
up and get stuff."
Yeah, I would leave my couch to walk the dog
or do stuff like that.
You know how sometimes you settle down on
the couch or in bed, and you're like, "Oh,
I feel so great," And then, you're like, "I
need that one thing, and it's over there.
Now I have to get up."?
I would love to eliminate that feeling from
my life.
I don't need that energy.
I thought about picking that one too, if for
no other reason, then it's towards the beginning
on the Harry Potter wiki of spells.
Yeah, because it starts with an A?
It does.
So I really considered it, and I was like,
"Let me put in a little bit more.
Let me try a little bit-"
It certainly does.
I did put more thought into it.
Don't make it seem like I just started at
the top of the alphabet.
Well, I know you actually know what you're
talking about with Harry Potter.
With me, I was like-
I have a Harry Potter tattoo, for God's sake.
Give me some credit.
You get the credit.
Thank you.
It's yours.
Tom, what about you?
What would you have picked?
Can we just take 10 minutes to try and guess
what Nina's Harry Potter tattoo is?
You don't have to.
There it is.
Yeah.
Can you explain that tattoo, please?
It is the stars from the corner of the books.
Oh.
Well, that is subtle and charming.
That's a perfect tattoo.
Thank you.
Good job.
Thanks.
Anyway, Tom?
Totally not what I would've guessed.
Yeah.
I don't want to know-
It's not a Deathly Hallows tattoo.
I don't know if you guys remember it.
It's kind of a mishmash of spells in the books
and the movies and you're not going to retain
all of them.
Just quickly, they're not always the same
from book to movie either.
Sometimes they change the names in the movie
to make it more obvious about what it is,
or whatever.
Yeah, so there's a lot of discrepancy.
And meanwhile, the canonical veracity of the
Lego Harry Potter video games.
It's a dumpster, Nina.
There is a spell.
I can't remember if it's in the book, definitely
in the movie that makes snakes disappear.
It's a specific get rid of snakes spell.
I pulled it up.
Vipera Evanesca.
There's also a spell to make snakes appear,
so a lot of magical energies got into-
That one's Serpensortia.
... situations where there're either too many
or not enough snakes.
And by the way, Evanesco was just a vanishing
spell.
They just put Vipera right in front of it,
in the movie, to make it really obvious that
that's what he was doing.
Fantastic.
So, just so you know.
Well, now we all know.
I'm really glad.
Wait, so you're saying that there's a spell
that just makes stuff disappear?
Yeah.
It's Evanesco.
Like, regardless of whether or not it's a
snake?
Yeah.
He could have just said that, but instead
they were like, "Kids are stupid.
Let's put viper in front of it."
That's a little bit of Latin in there.
Kids love Latin.
Interesting.
Okay.
They do.
Anyway, I don't run into a lot of snakes,
but I feel like if I ever did, that would
be a good one to have.
You just want to have that one locked and
loaded.
Yeah.
What if you're hiking and you encounter a
snake?
Great point.
What if you're at the mall and there's one
of those weird, exotic pet stores, where they're
hiring somebody who's definitely ... They're
getting paid less than minimum wage, and all
of the cages are made out of the cheapest
material possible, and yet, somehow, they
still manage to get their hands on like a
70 foot boa constrictor.
Yeah, no, one of those.
What if you're at the zoo, surrounded by screaming,
sticky children, then a snake escapes?
What do you do?
What if I am?
Well, I start chucking kids at it.
I was going to say you want to actually just
make trouble at the zoo and just make all
the snakes disappear.
Ooh, that's better.
Get the whole staff fired.
"How'd you lose all these snakes?"
Everyone at the reptile house gets the ax
because you made the snakes vanish.
They're like, "I don't know.
They just disappeared."
This brings up an excellent point, though.
The Harry Potter universe, it seems to make
a very big deal at three unforgivable curses,
right?
You get your killing folks, you get your enslaving
the minds of men, and then you get you're
torturing people.
But it seems like every spell in this universe
could potentially be pretty unforgivable,
right?
There's terrible stuff that you could do with
any of these, right?
Speaking to that point is Bryan, with his
apparent lust for getting zoo employees fired
for kicks, apparently?
I hate them.
Don't ask me why.
They know why.
Stop feeding pandas.
They know what they did to me.
I didn't say it.
Brian said it.
I'm not taking the heat for this one in the
comments.
Sure.
Take that, zoo.
Anyway, that's what I got.
Brian?
The big zoo industry.
Brian, let's get a little glimpse into the
mind that brought us "fire all zookeepers."
What would you do if you were-
My pick was called ... It didn't have any
fancy Latin.
They didn't give us that.
It's called, the Cheering Charm.
It makes you happy.
It does.
How useful would that be?
Drug-free depression cure.
Well-
Think about it.
You'd have to use it every second of every
day for that.
Well, it lasts longer than a second.
But I'm saying, like-
Also, doesn't it make people ... My recollection
from the books is it makes people giggle uncontrollably.
Only if you do it wrong.
You're describing the opening of Joker, where
he hands a lady that card, and he's like,
"I laugh too much.
Something's wrong with me."
There as a charm, there's a magic spell that
makes you happy.
It makes you feel elated.
And maybe, yeah, you're going to laugh.
I live in Minnesota.
It's winter here nine months out of the year.
Oh, I thought you meant, "It's winter there,
now."
I was like-
It's winter here, now.
No.
But I'm saying, you can go a long time without
kind of ... Some good days get dark and cold,
really cold.
Who wouldn't want to just kind of wave a wand
and say, "Oh, I feel happy now."
That's my pick.
Brian, the whole magical world at your fingertips,
and you picked a thing that could be cured
by a seasonal affective depression lamp and
a little sprinkle of an SSRI.
Really?
Well, look, I'm saying I don't need a prescription
for this.
I would have to go make a doctor's appointment
to use that.
You have a young kid, and you wouldn't even
pick the one where you just clean up stuff.
I didn't get that far in the Harry Potter
wiki.
Okay, I'm seeing what happened.
You got as far as C, and you stopped.
How far down on the page is cleaning?
What's that one?
Evanesco.
Oh, Evanesco.
Yeah.
I didn't get to E.
Call that a callback.
Comedy.
I stopped at C.
Wow.
Brian, you're my cheering spell.
See?
Aren't we all happy?
You're welcome.
Oh man, you've given us so much to think on
here.
I'm imagining you out in public, and you've
got your magic wand dangling from your belt,
and some kid's like, "Are you a wizard?"
And you're like, "Kind of?"
And she's like, "What can you do?"
And you're like, "I can make myself less sad."
Oh my God.
This has been such a dark exploration of our
minds.
You broke Brian.
I'm not crying.
Do you need a Cheering Charm?
"It's going to be more impressive in a couple
of years to you, but right now, it’s probably
pretty stupid.
Oh, time for the old magic."
Being an adult is hard.
Yeah.
It's a tough world out there.
I mean, look, don't we all feel pretty good?
As though we've all been cheered by the Cheering
Charm?
I'd also feel really great if I could summon
a sweatshirt right now, but, you know, each
to his own.
I guess that's fair too.
I guess there's a lot of paths to happiness.
Not having any snakes in your room.
That makes you happy.
Knowing that if you ever see a snake -
Not for long, buddy.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe; so you don't
miss a single video.